Sheriff's Office
[Music]
Sheriff's Office
hey sheriff's office right here
you okay
what's going on
I'm trying not to what I mean you're not
doing a real good job huh
okay well there's no need for 19. you
okay yeah
yeah huh okay
I stopped and just take a nap and uh
okay
damn I forgot I forgot to pass that
behind the gas station
I
asked the guy I stopped and I was like
man let me take a nap out back
the guy from the gas station or the
vehicle not a shop
no not not the Bottle Shop the Dude at
the gas station and he's like we'll be
here like 11 or 12. and um
and uh
I was like all right I'll just take a
nap for like an hour or nothing like
three o'clock I guess I got you sorry
try not to Blind you what's your first
name uh Justin Justin yeah
do you have a middle initial
huh middle initial
middle name
middle initial oh
come on
it's not that hard unless you're trying
to make up a name no man so I mean one
why are y'all messing with me huh I got
permission to be here
I don't know that
I got a call here about an alarm
checking out the property making sure
everything's secure and I find you
passed out in the passenger seat of the
vehicle and you're giving me a hard time
to give me your name
and it's past the hours of operation
it's not looking too good for you bud so
well I mean what time is it
my watch is dead but it's probably 3
30ish
maybe in the morning good go online yeah
alone
so what's your middle name
my name's will I don't know what Justin
no no no no no Wilson Wilson
do me a favor Wilson keep your hands up
on that Dash nope sit up sit up keep
your hands on that Dash where I can see
him you understand
foreign
with stuff in it
loaded syringe careful
scale
overseas passenger
foreign
and that's also out like that's not
normal for that to be
wish that
I'm almost taking this
It's actually an expensive dead blow
hammer right there but you know
foreign
hey
um
well a bunch of fitness
all right
okay well
let's
continue
[Music]
um